えー皆さんこんにちははじめしゃちょー
です本日2023年の2月の14日をもち
まして私はじめ社長30歳になりました
バレンタイン
バレンタインキース
やばいってもYouTubeを始めて今年
で11年目あの若手YouTuber大学
生YouTuberと言われていたあの
若き頃の大学生だったはじ社長は今やもう
30の20になってしまいました時の流れ
とはいかに無情になるか
30歳になったとしても私は変わらず痛い
そうは思っているもののやっぱりね体力が
落ちたね20代前半とかも徹夜とかもう
なんか不死身だったんですよ何しても
大丈夫だしやりたいことを何でも無限に
できる体力があったんだけどやっぱね
ちょっと20後半アラサー289ときて
もう徹夜とかはもう断じて無理と全然
できるんですよできてもなかなかこう体力
が持たなかったりちゃんと寝ないといけ
ないなとか体をいたわったりなかなか無茶
のできない年齢になったなと思っており
ますはじめしゃちょーです
30点
仕方ありませんそれでも俺は
変わらないぞと変わらないぞというとこ
見せてあげたい30にもなって30でも
いい年じゃないですかねいい年になって
30にもなってこんなことをしているのか
と言われたい俺は変わらずにこれが初めて
社長
Thisisはじめしゃちょーというもの
を貫き通していきたいです30になっても
というわけで只今の時間がですね今2月の
14日の1時半もう深夜ですよ
バレンタインの深夜今からですね私一人
社長30にもなって
深夜の渋谷のスクランブル交差点に行って
今から30歳の抱負を全力で再現できたい
と思います
叫びますよ深夜に
題名は上でしょう
統合おじさんと言われても仕方ないだから
俺は
尖っていきますよ早速渋谷に行ってきます
30歳の
抱負はこの年齢とか関係なく今まで通り
はじめしゃちょーらしすぎること
楽しみになってもあのバカなことするんで
儲からないでくれあとあの
結婚そろそろ
結婚できるかなぁ
[音楽]